[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing harry potter and some of the
unpopular opinions floating around the
internet regarding the franchise harry
potter casts a wide net and is
approachable to all sorts of different
people in many walks of life it's great
that the story is accessible and magical
to so many but what comes with such a
diverse group of fans is a lot of
differing opinions in today's video i'm
going to be selecting 15 unpopular harry
potter opinions from the internet and
sharing them with you all 15. quidditch
gameplay quidditch is a wizarding sport
played on broomsticks wherein players
try to score more points than the
opposing team
the game is played by two teams of seven
people three chasers two beaters one
keeper and one seeker and involves four
balls a quaffle two bludgers and a
golden snitch however despite the game's
popularity inside and outside of the
magical world many have questioned the
game's scoring system including one
reddit user what is the point of a sport
where people are playing for a point
here and there but then one player grabs
a ball scores a million points and ends
the game of course catching the snitch
is not technically an instant win it
only strongly suggests a win as catching
it results in 150 points 14. the books
have too many adverbs for those unaware
an adverb is a word that modifies a verb
an adjective another adverb or even a
whole sentence adverbs often end in l y
but some look exactly the same as their
adjective counterparts the criticism
floating around the internet here is
that rowling simply filled her books
with too many of these adverbs perhaps
running the risk of being overly
descriptive i certainly don't agree with
this one as i for one am a fan of
descriptive texts particularly as when
the books were first released we didn't
have the visual aid of the films causing
us to instead rely on our
imaginations
13. hermione should have ended up with
victor crum this is a weird one as we
know hermione ends up going to the yule
ball with victor crum durmstrang student
and tri was a tournament contestant the
unpopular opinion voiced here is that
hermione should have actually ended up
with victor crum instead of ron
this one to me makes absolutely no sense
i mean hermione spent the entire yule
ball trying to get him to pronounce her
name correctly for goodness sake 12. the
movies are better than the books this
one's going to wrestle a lot of feathers
and just remember that this is not my
opinion but the unpopular opinion of a
select few on the internet one reddit
user said the following i know they
removed things that were in the books
change some plots blah blah blah but
when you take the books on their own and
the movies on their own the movies are
just better some people aren't big
readers they simply prefer to watch
films and i think that they are
certainly entitled to their opinion
however what the films did is condense
the rich details and plot points of the
books which meant that a lot of things
were left out i love both just in
different ways 11. half blood prince is
the best movie if you ask most harry
potter fans what they thought of the
films and which film was their favorite
you'll very rarely get a response back
that says half-blood prince
however not everyone feels that way and
some have taken to the internet to
openly express their openness towards
the half-blood prince just maybe not for
the reasons you expected my favorite
harry potter movie is half blood prince
it's a terrible adaptation but i think
it's filled with so much teenager drama
it's actually funny and has so many
memorable moments i can't say i shared
the same opinion however i still enjoyed
the movie just not as much as some of
the others 10. neville should have been
the chosen one as we know harry potter
the boy who lived is the chosen one he
was the one born as the seventh month
dies with the power to vanquish the dark
lord however some feel that neville who
was also born at the end of july would
have been a better chosen one neville is
better than harry neville is more caring
courageous and dependable harry did a
lot of the legwork because he was
labelled the chosen one but neville was
the one who destroyed the final horcrux
in the end allowing voldemort to be
killed neville's a great character but i
think he was perfect right where he was
9. the goblet of fire is irrelevant this
is certainly an interesting one
particularly as the goblet of fire is
one of the longer harry potter books
though not the longest the argument here
is that the goblet of fire could be
nearly entirely eliminated from the
franchise and not much would change one
internet goer said the following book
film number four was irrelevant and can
be skipped on rereads and re-watches
without being confused
however others were quick to point out
that the goblet of fire shows how
voldemort came back to life
which is a rather integral plot point
eight the philosopher's stone is the
worst movie
now i take this one personally
particularly as the philosopher's stone
is one of my favorite films the opinion
in question here suggests that the first
installment of the film franchise was
fundamentally weak that every other
installment afterwards was an
improvement however the first film's
faithfulness to the events of the novel
paired with the immense levels of
childhood nostalgia makes it one of my
favorites
7. the epilogue was good ending a
massive story that has taken place over
so many years is no easy feat and while
i was left a little unsatisfied with the
story's epilogue i didn't think that it
was the worst thing in the world
i think i was more so just distraught
that the story was coming to an end
however the unpopular opinion here is
that the epilogue wasn't just not bad it
was good i certainly don't agree with
this one but i also don't think that the
epilogue was a total flop which many do
6. dumbledore was manipulative
dumbledore was the beloved hogwarts
headmaster of our childhoods and he was
the same headmaster that took a killing
blow from snape atop the astronomy tower
bringing a tear to many fans eyes
however not everyone was upset about
dumbledore's demise in fact some fans
think that dumbledore was actually an
extremely manipulative person who didn't
truly care about anyone else in the
story this is reinforced by a statement
expressing the dumbledore put those that
he was close to in danger all in the
name of the greater good this is a
tricky one and i can certainly see how
some would look at dumbledore through
this lens however at the end of the day
i think he's great
5. the time turner was a cheap plot
device the time turner was a magical
device used for time travel that
appeared in the harry potter series
notably being used by hermione in the
93-94 school year the time turner
allowed hermione to take extra classes
that her schedule would not otherwise
allow
and this eventually resulted in an
extremely stressed out hermione however
the time turner is also later used when
harry saves sirius black from the
dementors facing imminent death it
looked like sirius was done for
but thanks to a tip from dumbledore
harry ended up using the time turner and
saving him
some fans argue that this was a cheap
and easy plot device and that this whole
saving serious thing should have perhaps
been approached differently more
elaborately 4. harry's kids names in the
epilogue we see harry sending his
children off the hogwarts and familiar
scene at platform nine and
three-quarters there are a lot of
familiar things in this scene and this
includes the names of harry's children
james sirius lilly luna and most notably
albus severus
though the potter verse is a little
conflicted on the intentions of snape
and dumbledore over the course of the
books and films i think that harry
honoring them by naming his son after
them was meant to paint them in a
positive light however one opinion
floating around the internet is that
they were undeserving of this honor that
harry should have instead named his son
after people who were always there for
him people like hangrid remus or even
arthur weasley 3. voldemort had the
saddest backstory
voldemort isn't the type of character
that's meant to be given sympathy he's a
psychopath a murderer
and the primary antagonist in the story
he makes everyone's life harder and his
very presence threatens the sanctity of
the wizarding world
most people truly don't care about
voldemort and his feelings or rather
lack of feelings but one interesting
opinion floating around the internet is
that voldemort had the saddest backstory
of them all abandoned as an orphanage by
mother who died shortly thereafter
voldemort certainly had a rough start
the stance here is that voldemort's
actions were though inexcusable and
heinous rooted in hurt and tragedy
rather than pure evil
2. draco malfoy deserved better draco
malfoy was a pureblood british wizard
that hailed from the malfoy family more
importantly he was a slytherin student
at hogwarts and essentially harry's
rival
draco makes a poor first impression in
both books and films and he's portrayed
as the quintessential bully as the books
develop draco gets darker and darker
struggling with the immense pressure
placed on him by his family and the
death eaters by the time the books films
end draco isn't painted as evil anymore
but he also didn't really get a
redemption arc the argument here is that
draco malfoy became the person that he
was because he was a product of his
environment that he had no choice and
what this means from an opinion
standpoint is that draco simply deserved
better and i think that's a fair opinion
number one michael gambon was better
than richard harris if you didn't know
already two actors played dumbledore
first richard harris who played him in
the first two films and later michael
gambon who picked up the rest of the
films after harris died the argument
here is that gambon was a better
dumbledore than harris and though this
is quite a divisive topic i think i
think that a majority of people prefer
harris as he is generally considered to
be a closer representation of what is
depicted in the books however evidently
not everyone shares this opinion and
some have expressed their support for
gambon in the role explaining that they
could never have imagined harris in the
more action-packed sequences i for one
like them both just in different ways
and that's it for this video remember
these are not my opinions these are just
some of the opinions of the internet
what do you guys think do any of these
have merit which do you agree with which
do you not agree with comment down below
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams and forget to live